6 43 here on a wednesday morning and
welcome back to the program it is time
for our
morning cup of joe's segment with
sheriff joe lombardo sheriff good to see
you once again sir how are you today
good morning john good to see you all
right well let's get into things here
the legislative session is right around
the corner
uh you and i have talked before about
some of the issues that you think might
be on the horizon from a law enforcement
standpoint
what are you hoping lawmakers will
address up in carson city
well i haven't been privy to too many uh
deep
specific details to the bills that have
been presented
um you know every session we track a
couple hundred bills
on a regular basis but the devil's in
the details
obviously they change through time and
but specifically to law enforcement
we're we're tracking a bill
out of the attorney general's office
that addresses pattern
practice and what that is a data
collection
mechanism to determine why we
conducted our pedestrian stops or our
vehicle stops
is there racism uh systemic underneath
the reason for the stop it's just our
management
monitoring of that particular issue we
dealt with it several years ago
and that's part of the reform push that
we're all experiencing now
so we're going to pay attention to that
there's some modifications of the choke
hold
that we expect associated with police
work
uh public records is always on the on
the horizon
and how we address a media request and
public's request for our information
that's internal to the police department
and one thing in particular that i'm
really paying attention to is nako's
property tax initiative for those
who out there who don't know 30 35
of my budget involves property tax and i
don't know if there's going to be a push
to increase it or not but we always want
to keep
pay attention to that because it has a
direct effect on how we hire officers
and function on a daily basis within our
budget
but as far as us being proactive in that
space we don't i don't anticipate we're
going to have any individual bills that
we are carrying
to address any particular law um it's
more of a defensive posture
or a co-op you know that's not a good
word defensive
cooperative posture that we're taking
moving forward
sheriff i spoke a couple of weeks ago
with assemblyman roberts who of course
used to work for metro
uh and we talked a little bit about some
of the uh some of the
reform efforts uh do you believe that
there is reception
not even so much about the from the
lawmakers standpoint because you're not
obviously
up there but on metro's standpoint to
uh put in place some reforms that are
being maybe addressed
up in carson city well that that's
uh that card has already left the barn
we
uh a lot of the reform efforts that
you're seeing
nationwide that people are directing you
know like body-worn cameras and
and police officer discipline and and
duty to render aid and your force
continuum and de-escalation
all those particular items are already
in place here at las vegas metro
that's one particular thing i'm very
proud of we realized that was occurring
and it was on the horizon and something
we had to address sooner than later
it didn't take a significant event like
george floyd for us to act that was all
put in place prior to
now the surrounding jurisdictions
throughout the state of nevada
have some catching up to do and so a lot
of those things that people
on the tip of their tongue are on front
of their mind that they're talking about
and concerned with they're already in
place with metro
let's switch gears and talk about the
ride on capitol hill in washington you
and i have talked about this before
what have you learned so far about what
metro how many metro police officers may
have been at the event on capitol hill
and may have actually participated in
the riot
so obviously this is an ongoing
investigation
and today the best of our knowledge we
only had one
officer as part of lvmpd present
at the protest or the insurrection or
every title you're given it but that
officer was
able to be tracked he had a definitive
clothing description
and we were able to determine that he
did not enter the capitol
an interview with the officer himself he
also stated as such
he didn't participate in any civil
unrest
and he was practicing his first
amendment
ability to um protest or
express their views in general but so if
there was
any other officers involved we did have
an anonymous call in
we ran that down it was false there was
no validity to the call-in
and we haven't identified any other
officers okay
let's uh change also to talk about
security on the las vegas strip earlier
this month there was a fight there was a
shooting outside the palazzo
we've talked about metro's efforts to
step up enforcement on the strip dating
back to the summer
is that enforcement level still in place
and where do things stand with regards
to
enforcement there right now um
well no we've we've pulled back a little
bit it was called persistent pressure
and it was done
mostly through the summertime and then
we con continued it through the fall
um to deal with what was occurring on
the strip and everybody's aware of what
was great we had a significant
change in the demographics down on the
strip people were causing
being unruly releasing anxiety dealing
with the
different issues out on the roadway
versus inside the casinos
seeing that we adjusted our resources
and pushed our resources to the best of
our ability down there to address the
problem
so we affected 1200 plus arrests
we recovered 571 guns i believe it is
then that was directed that was a direct
result
of our proactivity of our police
officers what we expect them to do to
gain control of a situation now
the situation down there is completely
different than what we experienced
earlier in the year or the previous year
and
the crime numbers are bearing uh fruit
associated with that
so the numbers are positive um and what
i mean by positive it's it's good in a
good light
versus being actually positive of an
increase in crime
so we anticipate we're going to do some
proactive
human trafficking efforts down there in
the next coming months
and and i would say
keep a posture of honoring at this point
because it's just as important for us to
do enforcement in the neighborhoods
and make sure those resources aren't
depleted
in what we do on a daily basis all right
sheriff lombardo thanks again for
joining us this morning we appreciate it
if you at home have a question for the
sheriff you can submit it online
eight newsnow dot com you can find out
if it's answered every wednesday
ten minutes